[Music]
that's New York Democratic Congressman
Jamal Bowman arguing with Kentucky
Republican Thomas Massey over how to
stop school shootings like the one in
Nashville that left three students and
three adults dead it's understandable
that tempers flare and voices rise in
the aftermath of such horrific events
when faced with such situations the urge
to do something is nearly impossible to
resist but is Congressman Bowman right
that more guns lead to more deaths the
short answer is no over the past few
decades the number of guns in America
has increased massively so much so that
there are now more guns than people in
the United States yet federal crime
statistics say that firearm homicides
dropped about 40 percent between 1993
and 2018. for other crimes involving
guns the decline was 71 percent